[Applaudissements]
allier gone 12 93 ans sortis guéris dans
un hôpital d'istanbul après 10 jours de
traitement contre le coc u19 une petite
victoire pour les médecins et
infirmières qui ont laissé éclater leur
joie dans un tonnerre d'applaudissements
avec plus de 47000 qu'à la turquie est
l'un des dix pays les plus touchés par
la pandémie
la progression il est l'une des plus
rapides au monde
en première ligne face à un ennemi
invisible
les soignants turc luttent jour et nuit
essuyant eux aussi des pertes
un médecin et morts et plus de 600 ont
été contaminées le personnel de
l'hôpital où les équipes
tous travaillent ardemment comme s'ils
étaient en guerre l'ambiance ici ne
ressent pas un lieu de travail mais
plutôt à un champ de bataille
environ 60% des cas de couronnes à virus
en turquie ont été recensés à istanbul
ville tentaculaire de plus de 15
millions d'habitants et capitale
économique du pays
dès l'apparition des premiers cas en
turquie mi mars
l'hôpital ces rapaces a agrandi l'unité
des soins intensifs et séparer la
section dédiée aux nouveaux coronavirus
dont les entrées sont strictement
contrôlés de peur de contaminer leurs
proches certains membres du personnel
soignant dorment à l'hôtel ou dans des
résidences étudiantes reconverti en
centre d'hébergement afin de ne pas
infecter ma famille j'ai déménagé depuis
près d'un mois maintenant je ne suis pas
logées à l'hôtel mais je vis à proximité
avec un collègue médecin en isolement
une lutte qui se traduit aussi dans les
rues d'istanbul plongé dans un silence
inédit
les habitants des 30 plus grandes villes
de turquie n'ont plus le droit de sortir
de chez eux jusqu'à dimanche soir un
couvre feu de 48 heures prévue au
dernier moment et qui a créé un vent de
panique à travers tout le pays